I'm Ron Vale and today I have the
pleasure to be speaking with dr. Wally
Gilbert
dr. Gilbert started off as a theoretical
physicist and then through an
introduction from Jim Watson moved into
the area of molecular biology where he's
made many important discoveries over the
years he isolated a protein that can
control a genetic element the lac
repressor he's also made many important
contributions in our understanding of
mRNA but today we're going to be talking
about his seminal work on DNA sequencing
work that rapidly went to his being
awarded a Nobel Prize in 1980 so thank
you for joining us today and maybe we
can just start off by going through the
history of what led you in to tackle the
problem of DNA sequencing okay
the in the early 70s we knew of course
that the sequence of the DNA carries the
ultimate code is passed from parent to
offspring but in fact we thought it
essentially impossible to actually work
out DNA sequence and isolated the lac
repressor protein that binds to a region
of DNA in the early 70s I actually then
tried to isolate that region of DNA to
which the protein bound and we did that
by attaching approaching the DNA
dissolving all the rest of the DNA of
DNA and then isolated got a little
fragment left protected by the protein
so I had that physical fragment my hand
and I wanted to know what sequence we
tried to develop DNA sequencing methods
nothing seemed to work and we then
worked out its sequence my technician
now maxim and i were about two years by
copying that little fragment of DNA at
the RNA and working out the sequence of
the RNA by breaking you with enzymes and
using gigantic electric fredag apparatus
to separate the are in a spot some paper
electrophoresis if there was two years
to work out essentially 24 bases of DNA
it's about 1 base a month
we knew that a typical gene and bacteria
we thought the genes in our body would
be in the order of a thousand fifteen
hundred two thousand bases long we now
know of course the genes in our body a
30 thousand bases long far bigger than
many would have imagined at a time but
at one base a month you would never get
to a thousand bases of DNA you would
never be able to sequence anything and
that was actually the nature of the
problem in the early 70s the another
group worked out the sequence across
entire beginning of the lactose genes
again by copying the DNA and RNA and I
thought well that's so I'm interested in
the way of sequences go on work on
something else
a Russian a dreamer saveco came to visit
Lee and he wanted to convince me to do
an experiment when the convinced we
could look at whether the repressor
bound to DNA in the large group with a
small group by modifying the DNA of
chemical agents actually agent he liked
was dimethyl sulfate which a methyl
group on the guanine in the large group
I thought it would be possibly notice a
experiment but I didn't see a way of
doing it so I didn't do anything
six months later and the second part of
his trip to America came through again
we had lunch but again they convinced me
I should really do an experiment of that
kind I had the repressor I had the DNA I
knew had all access to all of this but
the question the problem was how can I
recognize where these modified bases
were in the DNA which repressive but but
in the conversations Ruth Andre we
thought of a way of actually trying to
identify the positions of these possibly
modified bases we could we had available
ways of breaking the DNA with it
restriction enzymes such as we could
isolate a piece of DNA about a hundred
different ice long which could be
labeled at one end or the other with
radioactive phosphate anything on the
way in which we had isolated the DNA and
broken it
sequential even restriction enzymes so
he could have available a DNA molecule
that we knew was bind to the repressor
had a label at one end and the
modification with a methyl sulfate we
knew would weaken the base to which they
might cut qualification occurred in such
a way that we could break with DNA at
that point so he reasoned since we knew
the whole sequence of this little tiny
little molecule we should be able to
break the DNA at the point at which the
methylations occurred and separate those
molecules by sauce on the gel and since
we knew the sequence we should be able
to decipher which molecule came from
what so I did that experiment I put
three pressure on the DNA modified it
second two had no no we press on that
DNA modified that methyl sulfate broke
the DNA ran gels and the experiment was
a great success
second time I did the first time it
didn't work at all second I did it
worked perfectly the guanine were
modified in a large group and you could
see yes we press her blocks of
multiplication or applauding the ad
means were modified the small group you
see yes we press her block certain
athletes but the striking thing about
that pattern which I expected to have to
deduce from the sequence what the
pattern should be the striking thing
about the pattern on the gel was that
it's separating the DNA fragments from
the smallest the largest we've got a
very characteristic pattern and you
could see oh here is DNA broken in a at
position 30 here's the next batch just a
little higher broken at a at position 31
well look at that pattern and say this
must be the sequencing method it's
sufficiently clear that one go I can be
essentially a hundred bases of DNA so I
was there are you Rica moment but
there's a moment you look at that to say
it clearly is a sequencing method the
only problem is can you actually
sequence just by looking at the A's and
G's we actually sequence something which
we never published just by looking at
the A's and G is coming down the two
strands and we started looking for
chemical reagents that would break the
DNA of cytosine C by means now in fact
we knew of such reagents immediately
because I knew hydrazine broke DNA at
cytosine some 5 mins
it's part of the old chemistry that we
try
five years earlier trying to work out a
sequencing method so he could
immediately get a display of the season
the teeth Allen maximum then spent about
nine months trying to find a way of
changing that display so that you could
distinguish the season T's essentially
by throwing every chemical in the
laboratory into the reaction to see if
they made a difference and he came up
with a modification by exalting the
reaction and that we ended up with
effectively four reactions each one of
which was specific enough to reveal a
breakage of DNA at a certain base and
they trick beyond the sequencing as this
idea of measuring a distance from like
point of wavelength Louisville phosphate
to the position of each base the first
gels would display molecules with the
order of ten to fifty or sixty long and
you could read that sequence we very
quickly went to gels it could display
molecules hundreds long and you could
read an afternoon well in one base a
month and in afternoon you could read a
hundred or several hundred bases of DNA
the next I had had a previous student
Nancy Maysles who had worked out 63
bases of DNA by copying an RNA for a
thesis the next thesis was about 1500
bases of DNA was the sequence of the lac
repressor gene itself worked out from
the DNA in that case correcting the
protein sequence which in which there
were mistakes that was the next students
thesis soon after that did 5,000 bases
of DNA did an entire plasmid we stopped
giving PhDs for sequencing the method
was actually developed around 1976 7576
and we gave the method away gordon
conferences the Gordon conference at
summer I think gave a little handout and
deal began the sequence DNA immediately
the paper official paper that polish Don
it was probably not published on 1977-78
took by that time people came to the
laboratories there the sequencing method
took it away how long did it take for
the time when you were working on the
problem from the repressor point of view
to developing this general method the
total time was the nine months to find
the last bit of the chemistry and the
sequencing came the the fact that you
could do the sequencing came immediately
out of that first experiment that me at
least said oh it's clear the patterns
are distinct enough Fred Sanger is
working on the problem of simultaneously
trying to develop sequencing methods
based again on hopefully the same idea
can I measure a distance along the DNA
to a position at which a base occurs we
used the gels that we used came out of
my laboratory the jealousy he also used
came out of the technology we had
developed in terms of sizing DNA
molecules and most of that technology
have been developed earlier just to size
DNA molecules and they call problem of
find isolate the DNA fragment bound
repressor and what was the reception
from the community when you first showed
these gels and meetings people begin the
sequence immediately I mean the
sequencing took off at that point both
threads method became available in our
method essentially the same time around
1976 and people around the world began
to sequence actively DNA rate of DNA
sequencing started to go up following
Moore's law doubling every 18 months
sort of from that time until public 2010
it may be going even faster now so just
looking at how how the field has
progressed since then when you first
developed this method did you have any
ID or anticipation of how the field of
DNA sequencing might develop it's a hard
question in the middle 70s where they've
developed a method and by the late 70s
it was clear you see we could decipher
any gene
and that's what people were doing
although everywhere and the Nobel Prize
is actually for the recombinant
technology is given after Paul Berg for
standing in full of people who showed
you could move with DNA fragment around
from one cell to another put in a
plasmid and grow and grow and grow a
human DNA fragment in a bacterial cell
and the friend myself for deciphering
for the ability to decipher the DNA
could do much good if you just moved DNA
around if you couldn't decipher it
across that period people within
sequencing genes like mad around 90 and
it was essentially the workhorse the
sequencing methods of those times Fritz
and mine were being used roughly equally
and continued to be fully until around
the middle 80s when the machines came in
that which they died out had met him to
be most easily adapted to and once the
machines came in then transmitted took
over almost entirely the chemical method
it's used only for very special cases it
could do certain things you die dogs
event they can't do to reveal the
methylation patterns and things like
that but beyond that it became sort of
specialty use I did not anticipate at
the time of the discovery of DNA
sequencing of the genome in fact in 1985
I was invited to a meeting in California
Bob Bobson summer and with a sort of
idea could one sequence the human genome
and I went that meeting thinking that's
the silliest thing I ever heard of
that's so much larger the things were
sequencing up to now and at the meeting
but I thought about where the
technologies had gotten to I thought
finally it's probably possible to
sequence the genome and I became at that
time in 1985 an advocate of the idea of
the s usual sequence the genome
originally I thought it would be at so
the 30-year problem I suggested to Bob
that he said we Institute the sequence
of genome
ten years for the first 1% ten years
with max 10 percent and 10 years for the
last and do it at sort of as an
industrial scale but 30 year problem it
actually took about 15 years it was a
purely industrial scale problem and I
can realize in 85 the technology that
then existed was improving at a rate
such that you could do the entire human
genome in a reasonable amount of time of
course by now the technologies have
changed radically from the first ones we
have we're now at least a third or
fourth generation sequencing so machines
and technologies out there and whereas
originally it was one base a month it's
now billions billions of bases in an
afternoon I find it sort of unimaginable
actually to being part of this entire
effort but the fact have seen it go from
nothing the time we were doing this or
the first DNA sequence Jim would be only
too willing to assure me that people
would never be able offer another decade
be able to sequence genes amazing
example of how fast science is moving
these days that's right especially in
the biological sciences
you